je crois que ce qui
est unique pour la savane c'est qui lui
font non seulement chercher la vérité
mais le proclamer
je crois pouvoir vous dire je crois
devoir vous dire même que l'émission à
laquelle vous allez assister ce soir
n'est pas une émission comme les autres
sans doute vous attendiez cela déjà à
propos d'autres émissions mais ce soir
seulement c'est vrai ce n'est pas une
émission comme les autres et voici
pourquoi d'abord c'est parce que l'homme
qui est en ce moment à côté de moi vous
allez voir dans quelques instants et que
j'ai ce soir le redoutable et intimidant
d'honneur de vous présenter mais pas un
homme comme les autres c'est un effet le
professeur Robert happenheimer dont je
n'ai pas besoin de vous rappeler
j'imagine qu'il est le père de la bombe
atomique de la bombe A et qu'à ce titre
c'est lui qui a ouvert cette terre à
domicile cet âge atomique qui sans doute
pendant longtemps encore nous plongera
alternativement dans l'angoisse et dans
l'espoir
roppenheimer a régné sur la première
grande cité atomique de l'os à la Mosses
et il dirige aujourd'hui aux États-Unis
une université qui elle non plus n'est
pas comme les autres qui est l'Institut
des études avancées de Princeton
une autre raison fait aussi que cette
émission de ce soir n'est pas comme les
autres c'est que depuis son séjour en
France qui dure depuis plusieurs
semaines Robert hopenheimer c'est dérobé
à tous les interviews que la presse lui
a demandé et cela donne un prix d'autant
plus grand à sa présence ce soir devant
les caméras de la télévision française
alors qu'il est à la veille de son
départ à nouveau pour les États-Unis
enfin troisième raison qui fait que
cette émission n'est pas non plus une
émission comme les autres c'est que elle
n'a pas été préparée qu'il n'y a pas de
scénario établi d'avance Robert
Oppenheimer a eu la gentillesse de
dérobée dans un emploi du temps très
chargé quelques instants avant son
départ pour venir devant vous et nous
pouvions guère lui demander de se prêter
en plus de trouver en plus dans son
emploi du temps le temps de venir se
livrer à des répétitions vous allez donc
voir devant vous
un homme dont le destin était il faut le
dire hors série et le spectacle pour
vous sera simplement de le regarder et
de l'écouter
je crois que oui mais pas beaucoup
je crois que la Sarah
doit chercher la vérité et s'il en
trouve il doit l'expliquer il doit
enseigner il doit être sûr que ce qu'il
a trouvé et bien compris pour
le plus souvent on le fait en publiant
en écrivant en parlant comme nous le
ferons à Paris ces journées il y a des
occasions
où il y a des lois ou des bonnes raisons
pour ne pas publier tes résultats parce
qu'ils sont dangereux
alors il faut être bien sûr la savane
doit être bien sûr qu'il a bien expliqué
ce qu'il a trouvé à son gouvernement
responsable c'est pas si c'est
il faut expliquer et
insister et il faut redire il faut
redire et enfin il faut que le
gouvernement reconnaît que ça vaut mieux
de le dire publiquement
de d'être ouvert et franche et
d'expliquer l'effet de la nature et les
implications si on essaie au public mais
il y a des fois où le savant ne peut pas
le faire lui-même
il y a naturellement toujours les
devoirs
pour tout homme et les savants sont
aussi des hommes
mais je crois que ce qui
et unique pour la savane
c'est qu'il lui faut non seulement
chercher la vérité mais la proclamer et
personnellement monsieur le professeur
comment éprouvez-vous c'est ce sentiment
des devoirs du savant en face d'un
certain nombre de problèmes est-ce que
est-ce que vous allez prouver des doutes
dans l'attitude vous devez suivre ou
j'ai eu des doutes je crois que nous
sommes nous ont tous eu des doutes
sur la pratique
pas sur la connaissance la connaissance
nous sommes pour la connaissance et pour
en savoir plus mais il y a beaucoup de
choix pratiques il y a il a de grave
raison humain et politique
ou les savants diffèrent mais où au
moins il faut
qu'il recherche à mettre
j'ai beaucoup de mesures pratiques mais
comme tout le monde pas ensemble
il y a une objection que le public fait
quelques fois ou en tout cas une thèse
qu'on entend quelquefois soutenir
monsieur professeur et qui est celle-ci
on entend dire quelquefois que devant
les conséquences d'un calculable que
peut avoir
le développement de la recherche
scientifique telle que elle existe
toujours
on se demande si il ne voudrait pas
mieux quelquefois arrêter si je puis
dire la science comme si l'on pouvait
d'ailleurs arrêter la science comme on
arrête un film de cinéma je ne sais pas
si c'est possible alors la question que
je vous pose c'est peut-on le faire et
doit-on le faire
on peut avoir
on peut dire oui on peut dire non mais
pour moi c'est mauvais de ne pas
connaître si on peut connaître c'est
mauvais de ne pas savoir ce qu'on peut
savoir ça veut dire qu'il faut
préparer tous les engins tous les
techniques pour pratiques que
l'assurance
permettre il ne faut faire tout le mal
que la science permettre mais il faut
savoir si on peut savoir je ne crois pas
que cette pratique de la réalité sur le
fait soi-même les autres vont le faire
je suis juste pas que c'est moral parce
que c'est le destin de l'homme de sa
voix tout ce qu'il peut et dans Vivre de
vivre avec cette connaissance c'est une
destin difficile mais si on
si on cède à sa pensée
ne tâche pas de vivre avec la
connaissance on n'est pas proprement un
homme du tout je nous ai posé cette
question d'ailleurs que je pensais
simplement parce que je pensais
m'attirer cette réponse je vois que
Monsieur le Prince ring et la prouve
largement
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas arrêter la
science c'est une des une des grandes
activités de l'homme l'homme est fait
pour connaître pour savoir pour
découvrir un peu plus de vérité pour
trouver des lois nouvelles pour faire
des expériences nouvelles c'est dans sa
destinée la plus évidente et on ne peut
jamais savoir quels seront en général on
ne peut jamais savoir quels sont toutes
les applications possibles on peut
deviner souvent on peut deviner parfois
certaines de ces applications par
exemple quand on a découvert la fission
de l’uranium on l'a bien pensé qu'il y
aurait de l'énergie qui pourrait être
libérée et encore là il y a de l'énergie
qui peut être libéré rapidement mais il
y a aussi de l'énergie qui est peut-être
libérée d'une façon pacifique et
bénéfique pour l'humanité c'est très
difficile quand pour le chercheur qui
fait la découverte de savoir et de peser
immédiatement les possibilités
ultérieures on ne peut pas le faire
surtout dans ce cas parce que le
chercheur qui faisait la découverte dans
sa verrait ça veut rien
mais j'ai un système le fait qu'il faut
savoir ne justifie
qu'on fait tous les engins tous les
méchants la Chine tous les applications
de ce savoir c'est là une question
humaine une question
de la survie dans la bienséance de la
communauté humaine alors il n'y a pas de
réponse simple à ces questions
monsieur le professeur vous avez
vous-même dit tout à l'heure à plusieurs
reprises que vous pensiez que le devoir
élémentaire du savant était de faire
partager ses connaissances au plus grand
nombre possible dans les cas où c'était
possible je voudrais vous poser
maintenant une question qui concerne
directement la science atomique
pensez-vous que le public en général
dans le monde devrait être tenu au
courant devrait être informé peut-être
plus qui ne l'est de ce que vous appelez
je crois l'actualité atomique et
peut-être même de ce que serait une
guerre atomique
je la crois bien ce n'est pas là la
science évidemment ce sont les
conséquences des mesures pratiques a
compris les gouvernements le
gouvernement américain le gouvernement
soviétique
je crois que c'est très important
qu'on a une idée bien claire et bien
fondée
de ce que ça reste la guerre atomique
j'ai l'impression je n'en suis pas sûr
que en France on n'a pas cette idée
claire peut-être pas non plus en
Amérique et je crois que c'est un devoir
des gouvernements d'être sûr que les
populations
sache
que
pourrait pas se passer et de quoi il
s'agit
on entend toujours souvent parler
des doutes que c'est
le peuple savait tout ce qu'il y a à ça
savoir
il n'aura pas plus du courage je dois
croire et je crois que le courage
consiste
avec
prudence et avec un peu de fierté en
face cet effet et pas en
se cache la vérité oui vous pensez
toutefois que ce devoir d'information du
public étant de voir qu'il y a un comble
non nos savants mais au gouvernement
évidemment parce que les faits sont
secrets et
il y a peut-être des moments où il faut
violer les lois mais c'est pas une bonne
habitude
personnellement ça vous personnellement
ce que vous venez de me répondre amen
cette question êtes-vous partisan ou
adversaire de la notion de secret en
général en matière scientifique tous les
savants j'espère bien qu'il n'y aura
plus de secret c'est très inconvénient
et pour les
questions graves de politique c'est
néfaste
dans mes intérêts professionnels pour la
physique de Monsieur
le secret n'a pas gêné beaucoup mais
pour la technique et pour la politique
ça gênait beaucoup et j'espère qu'il y
aura bientôt venir dans l'histoire
humaine ou il n'y aura plus de secrets
mais une ouverture une ouverture
franchise
affection une amour pour la vérité qui
est presque universelle c'est aussi la
vie de Monsieur le Prince sanguin oui le
secret a bien des inconvénients et vu
par les scientifiques eux-mêmes quand on
organise le secret et bien il y a
beaucoup de
d'inconvénients considérables il y a le
premier inconvénient c'est que la
science ne progresse pas comme elle
devrait progresser puisque il y a des
petits groupes qui travaillent en ne
sachant pas ce que le voisin fait donc
ce qu'on ne peut pas se réunir on ne
peut pas se retrouver on ne peut pas
parler des problèmes que l'on étudie et
puis il y a aussi une autre difficulté
c'est que les jeunes gens qui sont les
meilleurs on ne peut pas savoir où ils
sont où il se trouve tout est caché par
l'étiquette secrète
et puis enfin c'est l'introduction de
mœurs policière dans la recherche qui
est très grave parce que ça enlève
l'atmosphère de fraternité qui est
nécessaire pour faire de la bonne
science
en fait dans certaines disciplines le
secret n'existe pas par exemple quand on
étudie les rayons cosmiques on peut les
étudier sans secret mais il y en a
énormément plus qu'on ne pense dans
lequel le secret intervient je crois
même pour la connaissance de la
constante de la gravitation encore une
question monsieur le professeur
pensez-vous que le développement de la
science la recherche scientifique dans
un pays donné et peut directement
proportionnel à l'importance et au degré
de puissance de ce pays
on peut définir l'importance d'un pays
par ses contributions à la recherche
scientifique mais si on ne fait pas
si on de mesure par la richesse ou par
le pouvoir la puissance alors il y a de
grandes différences n'est-ce pas
après la conquête romain la graisse
était restée
au sein de la science et aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus que
son magnitude et son pouvoir le
correspondent à son agriculture et son
pouvoir c'est le cas en physique en
Danemark le professeur ni au sport
et le symbole de la physique atomique
alors des marques n'est pas une grande
que pensez-vous que va être d'une façon
générale l'attitude des gouvernements et
des États à l'égard des savants ce que
je pense
c'est peut-être pas tout à fait pratique
il faut les aimer
une dernière question monsieur le
professeur ne cite souvent en France du
moins je pense qu'en site aussi à
l'Amérique un mode Einstein qui dit si
c'était à recommencer je me ferais
plombier et vous
je souhaiterais contre la les conditions
de la vie humaine centaine qui ne faut
jamais répondre à la dernière question
[Musique]